earlier i spoke to kurt volker a former
u.s ambassador to nato and special
representative for ukraine negotiations
in the trump administration
when we spoke in january you said that
mr putin had put all the forces in place
for
a large invasion i'm quoting you there
and it was more likely than not that he
would use them
could we have done more to deter him
yes um it's unfortunate but true you
know we could see it we could see the
buildup of forces we heard his rhetoric
we knew he had made demands that could
not be met uh so it was just becoming
increasingly clear that he would invade
um i wasn't sure whether it would be
trying to take over the whole country
and depose the government or just take
parts of eastern ukraine and sadly is
what he is very clear about now is he
wants to kill zolinski decapitate the
government and control the entire
country
and you think that he
uh
really
is completely bent on his war aim now
come what may irrespective of casualties
and
international condemnation and so on yes
in fact i think he has given himself no
way out
uh he
launched this military operation on the
thought that it might last two or three
days it would be fairly easy they would
take over ukraine
obviously not true russian forces are
bogged down in many places they've
suffered a lot of casualties a lot of
equipment losses and now these sanctions
have kicked in that are truly
significant against the russian economy
so
he has to win to save face to save
himself to remain in power because if he
fails in ukraine and the economy is
tanking i would not be surprised to see
people in russia start to question his
leadership
do you think uh this is what might be
called the cornered rat problem
that actually
if you corner
the rat he or she will just become more
savage
and do things that
in other circumstances will be
unimaginable
yes that's true and we're seeing it
already so russian you know multiple
rocket launchers are firing at civilian
populations and apartment buildings and
cities in
mariopol
and
missile strikes on civilian targets in
cities
aircraft they haven't gained air
superiority yet
but they are trying to and they want to
completely suppress the population by
breaking its will and defeating the
military on the battlefield
mr biden
in his state of the union address this
week i i think devoted
not much more than about 10 minutes to
ukraine which
uh seems like a surprise given the
circumstances do you think that was an
indication that in reality the united
states
now thinks that there's relatively
little it can do to change
the course of mr putin's actions
well
first off i do want to give president
obama credit on two fronts one of them
uh he did speak extensively about
ukraine ten minutes in a state of the
union is significant and it's the first
topic he brought up
so he he gave it some priority
uh and secondly his rhetoric
about defending democracy and standing
up to putin's aggression
i thought that rhetoric was great the
problem is that the actions have not
matched that rhetoric and we have been
intimidated by russia i would say uh
fearing that he might reach for a
nuclear weapon fearing a direct conflict
with russian forces that could escalate
and so rather than deterring russia he
is deterring us
well you've said out uh this week in in
an article a number of things that you
think
that uh the west that nato could be
doing
and in particular um you've
taken note of what the ukrainians
themselves have been saying that they
want nato to establish a no-fly zone
you've called for that in a more limited
fashion i think than president
zielenski's talked about to cover kiev
and humanitarian routes out of ukraine
um how would that work
well uh first off uh we've done this in
the past we've executed no-fly zones
we've done it over the kurdish areas in
iraq for example when sodom hussein was
attacking them
so we know how to do this we there is a
protocol for this secondly we make very
clear this is for humanitarian purposes
only we are there to prevent attacks on
the civilian population from the air
and
we do this over kiev and western ukraine
so it's limited geographically we are
not coming close to russian borders
and we make very clear the rules of
engagement we will not be striking any
ground targets any russian forces unless
fired upon
and we will not be striking any russian
aircraft or helicopters provided they
remain outside the zone
and if they enter the zone then there's
a protocol with escalating uh tactics to
to escort them out
but if they refuse then there would be
the prospect of firing on them but many
ways to avoid that and i think the
russians will understand this as well
they might test us but then i think they
don't want to draw us into a larger
conflict either
well let me um
push back a little bit on that do you
really think
that mr putin
is going to play by rules that nato has
set out he hasn't been interested in
nato what nato has had to say about
anything thus far
yeah i think uh it's forced that he
respects it's force that he listens to
uh not um the the rules that are stated
so if he sees that we are doing it and
we are prepared to follow through i
think he will adjust
but of course what people
worry about is that
uh his reaction might not be
the reasonable one that that you've just
set out but simply to say this is an act
of war we are now at war and you know
what i'm going to do i'm going to win
this war with every force at my disposal
and we know what that means including
chemical biological and nuclear yeah
which which would be horrific and if
that is the kind of dictator and
aggressor that we are dealing with in
europe today then we also know he won't
stop at ukraine um he wants to subdue
ukraine he'll move on to moldova i think
that was already in the plans
uh he'll look at georgia and he may even
be looking at the baltic states which we
have an obligation to defend
so i think it is prudent to take steps
now to assist the ukrainians as they
have an organized government and
military and are fighting back rather
than waiting until it is disorganized in
ukraine and putin is in a dominant
position and moving on to other uh
pieces of the empire
let me ask you uh
i guess a question that i put you in our
previous interview if
we don't for example introduce a no-fly
zone
is it your view that ultimately the
ukrainians are going to have to submit
to russian control
no
i think the ukrainians are going to
continue fighting
and even if
the russians manage to kill zilinski and
even if they manage to break the
military organization
then the ukrainians will be fighting
from the cities and the woods uh in an
internal insurgency against a russian
occupying force this is going to go on
uh regardless
so this is potentially what our own
foreign secretary
called before the invasion the potential
for a quagmire for the russians um i
think she was
calling to bind uh afghanistan
maybe the first chechen war yeah the
difference between a quagmire as we
would understand it
and what would be happening in ukraine
under those circumstances is the
russians are absolutely brutal they
won't play by any rules of nicety they
will kill civilians indiscriminately
they will be incredibly brutal and that
is again another reason we should be
looking at ways to stop this before it
happens
um let me just ask lastly one thing
which as a former official
you've served under a number of
presidents
including president trump
it's been said to me actually on
television this week
that were president trump in the white
house mr putin would never have dared
uh to be so
audacious so brutal
so uh aggressive
do you agree with that
it's hard to know
it's hard to know
the um i think there is an element to
which president trump was highly
unpredictable
and i think putin was
uh not sure what trump would do
uh i also think that he believed that
trump was comfortable using force look
at the way we took out the head of the
iranian revolutionary guard
uh or uh you know pushed back um
in syria and against isis you know there
was a there was a bit of aggressiveness
in the approach
which i think putin saw and that also
increased uncertainty
but that being said
uh putin is bent on this mission to
rebuild the russian empire
on the ashes of the former soviet union
he wants to regather the territories
he's been explicit about it and so
i think his being driven to do this
would be the case whether it was
president trump or president biden